think story here with a quick Witcher
Season 2 casting update with some big
names in the mix for one of the
witcher's most pivotal characters so
just be warned this video may contain
some spoilers for next season arguably
the most important role everyone has
been speculating about is that of
vesemir one of the oldest switchers
remaining and mentor to Geralt names
like Michael Keaton and Mads Mikkelsen
have been floated around but both have
apparently declined the role leading
many to speculate that it will now go to
Mark Hamill so we may see the former
Jedi turning in his green milk for some
equally deadly witcher potions in other
news season 2 director Steven surge
extent Lee made a post on Instagram
tagging Christopher if jus alongside
Henry Cavill and Anya shell etre the
post was deleted shortly after leading
some to believe the Game of Thrones
favorite hit jus will be playing a
character named nivel in Neverland is a
character from The Witcher short story a
grain of truth about a cursed man turned
into beasts I won't spoil the story but
there are a lot of similarities to
Beauty and the Beast so having a former
wildling take on the role is perfect
next we have Lambert another Witcher who
holds some deep-seated jealousy towards
Geralt ends up helping vesemir and
Geralt train Syria at careworn so it's
likely season 2 will see us venture to
the ancient witch our stronghold much
like in the books he'll be played by
piggy blinders and bastard executioner
actor Paul bouillon speaking of training
Syria another witcher cohen has also
been confirmed actor Yassa Natur will be
playing the sword master who played a
significant role in the blood of elves
novel it seems we'll be getting a group
of witches coming together to train
serious she struggles to harness the
powers we caught a glimpse of in season
1 both Coen and Lambert are expected to
be in three episodes hinting that's the
amount of time we'll be spending at Kerr
Morin finally we have the mysterious
violet who's described as being a young
girl whose playful and whimsical
demeanor is a front for a smarter and
more sadistic character not much is
known about her but since she seems
about series age it's possible she could
befriend her for nefarious purposes now
we are still early in the casting
process was shooting on season 2 just
having started this week and is set to
go until late August
so make sure you like and subscribe to
get more with your updates I also want
to know who you think would be the
perfect vesemir in the comments below
you can also follow me on twitter at
think story whitey until next time
remember
[Music]